[Music]
i'm just
outside the israeli city of tel aviv in
a
town called hollon where a short time
ago
a rocket landed and as you can see there
is
glass on the floor there is
a bit of destruction the whole area has
been closed off by the israeli police
now three people were injured at this
location
including a five-year-old child it was
part of a barrage of some 130 rockets
fired by hamas and it says it was in
retaliation for
earlier israeli airstrikes so you can
see here
the glass has shattered on a number
of businesses that line this road now
this is exactly where the
bulk of the rocket landed it comes as
the israeli government urges people in
the center of the country
to remain in their bomb shelters
overnight
and this comes as hamas threatens
to increase the number of rockets that
it is launching at
israel the situation on the ground
remains tense driving here there were
very few cars
on the road so people are adhering to
that call
not to leave their bomb shelters at the
same time the israeli prime minister
benjamin netanyahu
has said he will increase the might and
frequency
of israeli airstrikes and we're hearing
from the israeli
security cabinet that they believe the
violence and the fighting
will continue for at least a few more
days at the same time as one rocket
landed here
another one landed not too far away and
actually killed
an israeli woman of 50 years old
the number of rockets fired from gaza so
far has been
more than 300 and it comes as the
israeli defense forces
calls up some 5 000 army reservists
soldier reservist
and it's doing this because it wants to
have the staff
and the soldiers capable to deal with
the situation on the israel gaza border
and also to deal with the growing unrest
in israeli arab cities so certainly the
mood on the ground on the israeli
side is a sense that the situation is
going to go from bad to worse
the situation seems very tense for the
moment
as the the territory is being
attacked by israeli war planes and
israeli
gunships actually and this
has come after israel bombarded
earlier this evening at our residential
tower in gaza city
which apparently means that israel is
intensively escalating
the attacks against gaza because these
are residential homes and containing
some apartments
with of people of inhabitants and
it has been reported that has been said
that a number of these high-rises
have been warned against israeli killing
in any moment
actually uh and one of these buildings
high rises
was hit by uh some rockets from israeli
drones
uh in a preparation apparently for for
gunning down or attacking this building
completely
the situation is very tense in fact for
the moment for the whole population in
gaza to more than 2 million people
fearing more escalation by the israelis
i was with my brothers and there was an
israeli bomb
i think it was artillery shell when i
saw the horrible scene of my brothers
lying around
i couldn't take it it was like a
massacre so many people were coming to
see what happened
and there were no ambulances or medical
aid at the scene
i'm shocked i can't believe it our
children were playing in front of our
house peacefully
they were hit by a bomb after we heard
it we rushed outside to find the
children lying on the ground
please stop killing our kids for god's
sake what would they do if it were their
children
enough is enough they've done enough to
us we're not resistance fighters or
militia we're not killing anybody we're
a peaceful citizen standing in front of
our houses
peaceful people who do not carry guns
knives or weapons
why are they doing this to us
my kids were killed both of them were
very young one was 11 and the other was
seven years old
playing near me they were playing only
30 meters away from me
my nephews were playing with them too
and a young guy called ahmed
who was getting married in a few days
they were playing and i was calling them
they were looking at me when suddenly i
saw a missile land right in the middle
of them
god my heart is broken i lost my heart
along with my children
god help me